[Music]
in but why news submitted by remember to
stretch very important like 23 year old
man was arrested and charged for three
poop attacks in four days yes
another poop attack now when we say poop
attack what are we talking about what do
you think we're talking about I think
he's [ __ ] his own pants who's that a
and a who's that in a tackle
I think he's [ __ ] into a PVC pipe
and blowing the guy here was it here I
don't know but he was [ __ ] in a
bucket and then throwing that on people
yeah was it oh that's not laugh yeah it
was homeless guy but very old guys in
where this guy's in Toronto oh well we
just talked about that so I've literally
just heard about this and I'm trying to
think like so if we're sitting here
right now somebody comes and throws [ __ ]
on us they got a bad like yup that
pretty bad that's chemical warfare right
yeah it's self-defense at that point so
yeah and it's definitely a so how we
have weapons
well since I already told this story
earlier might as well tell the story now
I had a homeboys whose friend came to
his house pooped stopped up his toilet
left why my homeboy and his girlfriend
oh they were in a toxic relationship so
they in the middle of arguing she
decides to go scoop the poop out the
toilet in the middle of the art way she
used to scoop one of those plastic cups
oh I thought her bare hair I thought I'm
like she's really no she's feel gravest
no but like go bare hands is crazy crazy
school she schools the poop tries to
throw it on his equipment he's a auto
engine oh no he's not he says no don't
you do that she turns around says fine
throws it on oh and it's not even his
own poop that's even that's
what he is discuss them he said any
hugger after that like oh yeah they
yelled and I don't know all the details
but you we're never talking again
wait he no wasn't his own poop his Hulk
of you knows homeboy as they bit he did
the toilet was stopped up the pump they
were waiting on the did fix it was in
the guest bath no what is this woman
doing these days like she needs to be
locked up
yeah knob seriously like you are not who
the [ __ ] that I had throwing poop like
monkey like we're just throwing your
audio equipment you're like like easier
to clean up your own poop so this guy
wakes up and is like so I'm trying to
figure out the deep does he have
different buckets of poop they're all
great questions that I wish I had the
answers is it what I do know though is
that he did a test so he had buckets of
poop he would go up to the top of a
building and wait for some poor
unsuspecting victim and dump the poop on
them and what does he get out of that's
kind of funny
yep I think he's laughing
yeah he's laughing on all puffy smiling
on the way they got a lot of you I did
not know this was a black guy
like a white guy prick see you but
that's Canada though that's Canada's lot
of the whole way there
yeah the construction hand like he's
gonna go to work is he mentally insane
Oh Joe I'm very disappointed okay here
like he's covering it there's a bucket
of poop where do you get this hole how
long is it taking the harvest this is
cool dude just like so recently we when
we were talking about that homeless guy
on Hollywood yeah he dumped warm
diarrhea he was saving up and he poured
on this poor woman who now has PTSD
because of it I'm sorry she doesn't get
therapy they went in her mouth and her
eye her car it was somebody else's so he
was a saving saving it you can't save
money no I'm saving this for somebody no
he was definitely made [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] but now with his finances that
and what point do you wake up in your
life be like you know what today's the
day I'm gonna start doing I'm psyched on
poopy or is that woman like she's like I
never win anything
I got you today hey today you're the
chosen one so but they arrested him so
they actually finally got the guy cuz he
was they were looking for him for some
time but damn it took a while huh we got
like a few days and so it's hard when
there's [ __ ] falling down you don't know
there are people yeah exactly and there
are people that were so scared to even
go outdoors it was happening it was a
that was the news out there that's how
safe it is the [ __ ] bandit is off be
careful watch your heads when you're
walking around on the news it is like
turn to the dog yeah this just in guys
protect yourself we have a shooter on
the loose bring umbrellas you we don't
know where he's at right now he could be
like that is scary as well no that's why
they used to walk with umbrellas to is
because they would just throw [ __ ] out
of their windows back in it I guess
we're going back to what we used if
you're walking down the street and
[ __ ] this brown Dookie hit you in the
face
do you first go like wait how do bird
should get this big or do you first go
that this is human it's watery [ __ ]
picture it it's like you could not
almost get it my shouldn't not know it's
[ __ ] yeah you're not gonna know
immediately personally what the [ __ ] is
going like what's he's sifting through
it making sure it's very refined right
nuggets he's like I'm just getting the
Nuggets out yeah no nuggets ah you're
not gonna be at you gonna be mad but
Nuggets are gonna know he got he wants
to make sure this this sticks that is
Tim now imagine you're on your way to
work and you get some [ __ ] thrown on you
and you call in the Senate doctor
did you mail this [ __ ] on look at this
I'm having a shitty day I'm not trying
to be here that is [ __ ] no it sounds
[ __ ] fighting but imagine being the
victim not gonna have to question that
guy just ask him why I know
so yeah they did arrest him it's a this
23 year old man named Samuel and so he
was charged with five counts of assault
with a weapon and five counts of
mischief wait a soul you know sometimes
like they have the like the prisoner sit
down with the family I've seen stuff
over they sit down with the family and
family ask him like you know what made
you do like imagine sitting down but
years later
why why why did you feel like you had to
throw [ __ ] on me worse if you knew the
person oh if I know the person it's a
raffinate I better not ever see them
ever again in my life
because it's gonna be problem you can
you imagine being the victim at
Thanksgiving it's like so what's new
lately what's new lately I guess it it
uh oh you better do back what's going
beautiful but that's how you get a free
trip though oh they get a free trip so
how much how much time do you think they
should get though like for shitty [ __ ]
like but don't [ __ ] on somebody cuz they
do that for fun you know does he get a
wife sick like but throwing [ __ ] only
thinking do it where like they just tie
them up and you beat the [ __ ] out of
them getting [ __ ] out of them yeah I'm
gonna poop in a bucket you're gonna
[ __ ] have my [ __ ] all over you okay
so each victim should get the poop in a
bucket to have some men dream about them
that's right you want to [ __ ] on you in
any way and I at least I'll have my
pleasure of knowing well you know if he
enjoys it if they're home with me it's
jerking off though you do it yeah rocks
in the [ __ ] and then they'll double it
it'll be like well you've been eating a
lot of iron lately he's like I was gonna
jerk off to it but I see there's some
kind of rock scene from [ __ ] Silence
of the Lambs where you can just do like
jerk land in her [ __ ] face oh my god
whatever reminded me of the jizz on her
face
yeah wait on purpose he's jacking off
the land on Jodie Foster spiritually
seventh of the glans is ammonia and then
like it's the first Hannibal Lecter
movie right yeah yeah yeah and then she
goes bit to visit this due to the prison
and then this other crazy prisoner was
there
so he's jerking off and then like the
whole time like she's walking there he's
drinking off and then on my way leave me
time dude he goes back he lands in her
face that is amazing aim and timing
that's a lot of for us
he's like all right here mine would have
been like all right it's like ah even
out of the hand even pitching it just
goes it's more like I can't win I can't
do I'm in jail like any [ __ ] Supes
worm the right way out [ __ ] get stuck on
your hand come into you're doing some
shitty things to be like in solitary
confinement cuz you just can't stop
[ __ ] on people like you in his cell
me oh no they'll kill him [ __ ] [ __ ]
guy do I smell anything coming from you
it's a rap you better habitat smell
nothing female corrections officers deal
with that [ __ ] though oh I heard yeah
they want my and [ __ ] on it yeah cuz he
trying to try to get spank bank material
so they like to try to come on them try
to throw poop on them and all kinds of
[ __ ] trying to pee on us like how do you
get turned on by Statham maybe the
reaction it's humiliating
oh oh whatever I heard guys enjoy
usually don't think straight
[Music]
you